[Musique]
ici
Je ne cache rien il n'y a rien à cacher
ici j'ai fait la chose la meilleure et la plus fière
que j'ai fait ce fier ce qu'il a fait quoi
Qu'est-ce que tous les médecins ont fait de Diego ?
et évidemment désolé du résultat
mais je vous garantis que le meilleur a été fait
avec tous une équipe très nombreuse pas quoi
Je pense à tout plusieurs fois je souhaite que
avoir
me reprocher
je ne sais pas pourquoi
il voulait une vie qui était mauvaise
J'ai essayé d'accompagner tout
même ceux qui ont donné des coups de pied n'ont même pas voulu
cheveux que j'ai déjà enlevés
Je crois que la justice est
enquêter sur une procédure I avec le
famille je m'entends très bien surtout
avec toi fixant toujours peu
J'essaie que le sol soit Diego et le
aura
nous étions étreints et sonnant je le dis
c'est un absolu du tout tu sais que je suis
responsable de prendre soin de l'aimer
aidez-le à être quand tout le monde
il a dit laisse ce gars parce que si ça lui arrive
quelque chose va être un gâchis parce que tout le monde
ils vont rester à portée de main et ceux
bêtises et j'ai mis la poitrine parce que
c'était mon bon ami j'allais le laisser tranquille
Ce sont des choses qui vont être étudiées, mais
ce que tu me dis ne change rien
mal
tout le monde voulait qu'il soit dans un
maison contrôlée de tous côtés sans
alcool et tyc et avec toutes les pilules
Je le voulais, tout le monde le voulait
il le voulait je ne sais pas
il est mort naturellement
vécu beaucoup de choses
n'avait qu'à supporter
et je savais qu'il était malade, oui
personne ne l'a aidé
monter et descendre c'est pire j'ai essayé
faites de votre mieux avec un
patient très complexe je suis fier
de ce que j'ai fait pour lui et pour plus qu'aujourd'hui
Dimanche je serai avec ma famille dans le
piscine ici avec toi je le referais
rendre tout pareil pour lui
très conscient
et c'était le plus dur
parce qu'il savait comment il vivait
J'ai choisi sa vie tout du long
il a choisi sa vie tout le temps qu'il
a choisi d'arrêter d'arrêter de cocaïne